[Applaudissements]
alors la deuxième partie alors
maintenant ça va être la partie que
j'aime le plus c'est la logique et les
calculs logique de calcul
alors d'abord avant doit avant de passer
à la loupe ses calculs je veux savoir
les études que vous avez fait qui a fait
des études scientifiques doc gynéco vous
êtes vous content mais tu do we
commencer par ça fait bien j'ai étudié
en vises esquissé ce à quoi j'ai pas
beaucoup l'idée davis oui chez bricorama
wuala non non j'ai sinon j'ai fait de ma
question est claire quel est ton cursus
alors dany moi pas grand chose un voeu
porte de la chapelle
alors moi j'avais eu le bac
non et je vais demander si la bulle pas
combien je vais vous avez une maladie
non et pourquoi d'honneur gilles verdez
et fais quoi moi j'ai fait un dea
d'histoire et naissantes géographie donc
littéraire d'accord il pose mais vous
moi effectivement j'ai fait des idéaux
finances assez haut placées avec d'actus
cet analyste financier normalement la
pâture addition il doit faire un dix sur
dix statues on vous met pas la pression
mais vous devez faire un dix sur dix
statues il ya eu une question il voulait
faire a dit sur dix c'est possible
maxime qui vous ai fait voir un bac
littéraire plutôt option cinéma théâtre
et au cinéma
l'activé ma mais pour quoi faire j'ai
des options en plus les options et un
peuple 5 en infos comme d'accord et j'ai
dû me communication et journalisme
d'accord voix très beau daniel mon moi
je fais beaucoup de latin et grec
un bac littéraire et ensuite un bts de
secrétariat direction parce que ça
rassurait ma mère l époque s'était
longuement temps à l'époque j'ai tout
dis moi c'est vrai qu'en fait on
remercie en latin mon propre qu'il
trouvait que je faisais trop bruit média
zinou saisine ou le fric adlane
fréquentes klahn la femme est toujours
restée à l'est c'est vraiment pas fait
exact est sa logique et quelle pub bah
moi je pense que mahler à qala i naw
tient bon la tuer puis il a perdu
tellement d'argent qui doit trouver
allez c'est parti
première question celle ci avoue prendre
la tête il faudrait pleinement 15
secondes mais on croit que c'est facile
mais c'est une petite anastasie quel est
le résultat de cette opération 0 45 1
générés par mille
allez on y va beat personne ne triche
pas bien entendu on ne triche pas celui
qui triche reste en friche rappelle
qu'il est complet mais si on travaille
ça on déjà tendue alors on va d'abord se
tourner vers doc gynéco qu'est ce qu'il
a répondu loeb gynéco 450 et ben voilà
donc vous savez que ça ni à 450 c vous
déjà comme ça on élimine directement
benjamin castaldi aurait répondu quoi
moi je me suis gouré chimiques à la
207,5 sinon il n'y a que des bonnes
réponses que ces 45 alors qu'il ya un
truc très simple au décalé la virgule
voilà donc pas là vous passez à 0,45
comme ses adversaires et enfin 45
franchement vous auriez vous attendez
attendez d'eux me connais je crois qu'on
pose une question est si ça où l'on tait
l'argent il aurait pu devenir vous aussi
vous êtes forts en maths
ouais c'est votre domaine h avec ed wood
domaine des marges devraient coûter plus
ces lettres
ah oui tiens et l'effort en taux non il
est fort en soustraction dans mémoires
pour les salaires non mais vous
connaissez le portable de tout le monde
quoi connaissez le numéro de portable de
tomber ses valeurs
les donateurs
je vous dis 06 12 à beinheim mer la bnm
alors je vous le dis ici non il n'y a
que des bonnes réponses et magali berda
a fauté c'est pas les chiffres est passé
en revanche et agnel moreau toujours des
bonnes réponses bravo d'accuser moi je
dois benoît benoît dubois j'ai ouï non
non benoît dubois il faut quand même
jouer doit revenir la paix dans leurs
intentions
question quels chiffres se cache
derrière le point d'interrogation ou le
regard des 15 secondes celle là c'est
parti en fit un sas et des suites
logiques à aller passer des suites
logiques vous expliquera après lé sud
angola je comprends rien alors là alors
là c'est facile à deux c'est facile
rappelez-vous des carrés magiques chez
vous ah ouais non alors je vais vous
dire
et puis je vous expliquais il faut
compter ouais en horizontal +9 égalent
11 +4 égale 15,6 plus un égale celle ci
et là je fais un kiff
[Rires]
alors je me suis fait alors c'est très
simple j'adore 6 plus un égale cette
puce suite égale teinte donc c'est plus
5,12 donc ces trois bus 3 3 et galtan z
avez la somme issue c'est moi pour
répondre à 15
il fallait donc répondre 3 doc gynéco
j'avais répondu quoi 3,6 et jardins non
il a répondu la réponse donc tiré du sac
pourquoi vous avez répondu 5 eh bien
j'ai pensé que logiquement c est l a3
mais pas cinq quotidiens
j'avais page interverti le 3 et le 5
n'avez rien compris en fait trop alors
je veux dire qu'elle vivait novelli faut
également à j'ai pas cherché à
comprendre moi j'ai les flots piste
n'avait rien compris de tous là n'ont en
effet pas fait franchement j'aimerais
qu'on vous étiez dans le brouillard
ouais d'accord très bien tu l'as eu le
temps alors personne géraldine maillet
isabelle morini-bosc valérie et benjamin
apple tend pas à bernard rappaz 95
secondes ça fait partie des tests il
faut être rapide mais également chez
vous n'en prenez pas ce qu'on me
demandait un peu on n'est pas ce que
vous demandez paribas c'est normal c'est
pour ça que vous êtes ici en revanche
matthieu delormeau bonnes réponses deux
bonnes réponses sur les chi l'argent et
le sexe
ce sont les deux mamelles de ma vie
c'est vrai mais j'ai bon chef non dans
les possibles est bon mais il faut
parler de masse et de lanvaux oui merci
qui revient très fort dans la course
novelli mais mon coeur attention
question quelle forme remplace le point
d'interrogation
aïe aïe aïe le carré avec le carré à
l'intérieur le carré avec le rond à
l'intérieur la croix avec le rond à
l'intérieur ou le carré avec la croix à
l'intérieur je crois qu'on a perdu
canivez novelli
c'est nul c'est truffe à l'arrière bon
bah si on n'avait pas bonne garde bah
oui c'est clair et aurait là ma poule
alors on va demander la doc gynéco ce
qu'il a répondu
3 j'ai répondu 3 donc la croix avec le
rond à l'intérieur alors je vais vous
dire je vais vous expliquer tout ça et
vous allez tout de suite comprendre
quelle est la bonne réponse
la première ligne de gauche à droite
vous avez mais la croix qui s'insère
dans le cercle mais à ceux envoyés ou
pas la tac aux cantons pour y croit plus
cercle à quoi rentrer dans le cercle
hostel à deux deuxièmes carrés rue le
car est rentré droit est donc là qu'est
ce qui va se passer la balle à deux la
2s carapace entre deux rounds et bien le
carré le carré la roja est rumineront le
rhône
l'euro va être dans le carré plutôt
voilà à l'intérieur dont le carré avec
le rond à l'intérieur et donc seignard
ne plus bonne réponse c'est très dommage
comme quoi le hasard vous expliquer les
gens nous d'expliquer vous l'avez
vraiment pas me we stand speakers dany
vraiment à temps a laissé la rive bien
sûr vraiment web et le but qu'elle a
donnée la racine carrée de sède alors
promis d'user que c'était nul alors pour
induire les autres en erreur non parce
que je n'étais pas sûr de moi mais après
en y réfléchissant je me suis dit tiens
voilà ah ouais mais en tout cas c'est la
seule bonne réponse déliver novelli je
pense que chez vous aviez des bonnes
réponses mais ici sur le plateau c'est
morne plaine
je vous le dis on verra j'ai hâte de
voir vos résultats et de voir qui est le
plus gros puis et celui qui sera le
dernier parce que je pense qu'il va y
avoir des surprises ce soir ça chez vous
pour l'instant vous n'êtes pas au top
mais logique et quelques unes pourrait
même mettre zéro sur la limite tout de
suite nommé que j'ai de vous battre
comme un but à la 80e mondiale doit elle
voit pas les crosby a pas joué attention
attention là concentrez-vous puisqu'on
est toujours dans la logique à calcul et
je vous posais une question j'ai opposé
un problème chez vous aussi
benjamin castaldi 1 doit verser des
pensions alimentaires à ses ex femmes en
suivant un ordre établi
voilà il doit verser un
c'est un ordre établi à l'avancé qu'ils
versent 1000 euros à sa première femme
première ex femme 1080 euros à sa 2ème
ex femme 1014 euros à sa 3ème ex femme
et enfin 1018 euros à sa quatrième femme
combien de matchs il verser à sa future
cinquième ex femme 1016 euros 1020 euros
1000 22 euros ou 1024 euros vous avez 15
secondes aller vite il reste plus que
dix secondes
benjamin castaldi en plus ça va pouvoir
lui dit et de montrer ce but où il va en
être à la fin de l'émission c'est une
suite logique également
je vais vous expliquer au début benjamin
castaldi
il donne 1000 euros ah oui après ses 8
euros de plus oui lui néanmoins depuis
ces six jours peu après ces quatre aux
dombasle a donc là ça va être deux os x
et linux et 1020 euros la bonne réponse
il n'y a que des bonnes réponses à par
doc gynéco géraldine maillet et kelly b
2h22 que vous avez mis vos top 16
pourquoi et diminuait il a diminué
j'ai fait dans le sens inverse il a pris
dans ce sens inverse vous saviez pas vu
que c'est allé crescendo
ouais ouais non mais parce que vous
dites crescendo mais chez nous c'est
comme ça
écidément s'est dit les maths le
français est monté dans un marasme chez
des personnes de l'éducation nationale
nous regarde
on n'est pas bien on n'est pas n'est pas
bien alors je vous donnais les résultats
bien sûr ont fini toutes les questions
je vous donnerai les résultats après
dirait on en est après cette deuxième
partie est
attention quelques jours vient cinq
jours après le jour qui précède le
samedi à nantes et shirel jour vient
cinq jours après le jour qui précède le
samedi jeudi mardi mercredi vendredi
ça c'est ça c'est cette échéance ne me
lasse hyperfestive ça c'est une canne
ista moi je déteste ça je n'existais pas
vain sa chérie moi je déteste c'est un
blog avec les doigts là réside toujours
l'homme que je vous entends pas en
régime
ils sont décédés merci alors qu'elle
joue revient cinq jours après le jour
qui précède le samedi quel est le jour
qui précède le samedi c'est le vendredi
donc quel jour vient toujours à cinq
jours après le bac à déchets mercredi
samedi dimanche lundi mardi mercredi
jeudi mercredi à huy était la plus
redoutée des mois parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un proposait n'arrive pour rien
vous j'arrête elle trouve ça trop facile
dans ce cas là c'était hyper facile mais
bon quelque chose tu as plus facile
[Rires]
aussi à la retraite fonctionnent bien et
va lui croit que c'est la plus jeune
c'est elle à l'esprit très grand oui
mais si tu veux dire à part isabelle non
mais par rapport à vous à vous la
poussez un peu
doc gynéco vous avez répondu quoi mais
vendredi je voudrais arrêter
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il me parle pas merci donc pas tendre
dit je me suis arrêté à la première
semaine
non c'est à dire de calcul vous avez
pris en compte deux semaines et à 15
secondes alors hop vendredi une chance
sur quatre de trouver juste déjà des
lacs est bien c'est que je pense
voilà à 21h22 pour vous dire déjà qui va
être le dernier
il reste quand même pas mal tu peux
quand tu auras ta paix à celui lui c'est
quelqu'un sur troisième trimestre ce qui
donne donc c'était bien le mercredi les
chéris mercredi attention question
toujours nous sommes dans la partie
logique et calculs espère que vous
amusez bien chez vous et vous faites le
test en même temps que nous donc moi je
me régale je vous donne les résultats
dans un instant de cette deuxième partie
de chroniqueurs et la plus lourde
le lourd de regarder vers par rapport à
ses petits benjamin castaldi jean michel
maire gilles verdez matthieu delormeau
quelle tête de chroniqueurs et la plus
lourde ne pensez pas bien sûr dans la
vie voit que à cénac et alors
alors oui alors que tu fais l'amour
c'est que ces quinze secondes avant
toute chose
doc gynéco vous a répondu qu'
saint-germain castle pourquoi pourquoi
attendait c'est peut-être la bonne
réponse pourquoi bien alors parce que
mathieu les lui soupèse la tête et donc
on voit que mathieu à la tête la moins
lourde
non c'est le contraire alors il ya plus
lourd alors quand ça penche d'un côté
vous avez déjà été faire des courses
quand ça penche d'un côté là elles ont
fait leur entrée
benjamin castaldi ne peut pas tout
puisque voyez on a déjà matthieu
delormeau à la tête et à burgault
toujours comme un cadeau l'a dit donc
c'est pas ça ça ne passait pas c'était
pas le cépage à main castaldi qu'est-ce
que vous avez répondu qu'elle ivanov et
10,2 j'avais dit cui jean michel maire
je vous dire pourquoi ça peut alors quoi
s'enflammer retient la vérité non mais
ça ne peut pas toujours achevées
l'espère oui ce que gilles verdez est
plus lourd un peu comme gilles verdez
est moins lourd que benjamin castaldi
mais benjamin castaldi c'est moins lourd
et matthieu delormeau et ben je vais
donc matthieu delormeau qu'à la secte a
fait le classement et match de l'ormeau
puis benjamin castaldi gilles verdez et
bien jean michel maire mais il n'ya que
de leurs mains et aprilia c'est matthieu
delormeau qu'à la tête la plus lourde il
n'y a qu'une seule bonne réponse et
c'est jamin castel markus babbel chine
la finale a battu vous avez été
exceptionnel pourquoi parce que sa mère
halima peur non parce que je me suis vu
plus plus léger que mathieu et après
match et toujours plus lourd mais
forcément hors série les outre vous avez
été très mauvais la tuerie
trop tard et c'est là bas ça monte
a répondu mathieu n'avait pas répondu
matthieu lahaye alors peut-être si vous
avez répondu mais pas mathieu par
mathieu et moi j'ai mis quoi chef vous
avez mis je ne veux je ne suis pas vous
êtes qui je crois que moi vous c'est une
bonne réponse physique estime crédit
également ahmed pas voilà bien sûr on me
dit que vous avez une bonne réponse mais
enfin je le vois là sur mon dernier
dogues ce que on vous a comptabilisé une
bonne réponse
ouais attention question 7 de logique et
calculs regarder et trouvez moi
le domino manquant à mais là c'est un
peu un deux trois ou quatre de dominos
manquant la mouche merci
dès que tu veux tu me donnes en direct
c'est un bijou c'est toi le bichon bas
comment faire pour répondre que si sa
mère n'est pas pour me déplaire
alors attention moi aussi un galet s'il
vous plaît calais le domino manquantes
si le domino manquons 1 2 3 regardez
bien ce que vous expliquez c'est une
suite de domino de la même famille si ce
que celle du 4 vous le voyez bien un 4 1
4 2 4 3 4 4 4 5 et bien sûr bien sûr
après ça va être quoi
cécile a atteint 6,4 puisque s'est
inversée voilà le domino avec le 600e
leurs quatre ans bat benjamin castadi
bonne réponse benhaim aussi jean michel
maire j radine
le reste c'est plus compliqué il ya une
autre façon et là ça fait 1 2 4 5 6 oui
mais c'est pas quand ça marche aussi
voilà bah ouais mais c'est pas comme ça
qu'il fallait faire sa valise de marche
pas comme ça que ça va je n'appelle pas
ça marche aussi
alors là non la glace chiche était sur
une copie de romy le résultat est bon
mais pas le réseau du jeu mais je le
vois et je dis vous avez de beaux restes
dans l'éducation marie curie souhaite
plein de trucs quoi il n'a pas été
patient d'avoir mon prof devant moi je
vous dit vous voyez pas si bien dire il
est mort mon prof de maintenant vous
avez d'autres vous qui fait d'être prof
la bombe ont déjà des projets qui peut
plus se voit si peu de temps je promets
de graves comme quand je chante mais
vous la fête du chant moules à la grotte
chauvet la lampe les envoie à cet
individu
l'animal est bien quand vous étiez pas
là ça fait plaisir de voir aussi
attention dernière question de logique
et calculer le nombre remplacent les
points d'interrogation on adore même
temps on adore attention là vous avez 20
secondes
ou est-ce que ça evans chez vous des
relations sait comment gérer l nombreux
remplace le point d'interrogation
vocation à la barre a oui là-bas attend
là-bas missionnés sur sa calculette pour
vous sachez qu'on vient fait la feuille
combien fait voile alors gardez bien
emmerdé but de bois merde alors quelle
est la bonne réponse
je vais vous reposer la question elle ne
remplace les points d'interrogation
c'était cette question qu'on vous a posé
il y a un instant il fallait lire
regarder les symboles doc gynéco vous
indique un seul instant qu'il avait
répondu la réponse
trois vagues généralement quand doc
gynéco donne une réponse c'est la
mauvaise
regardez de la bonne réponse elle nous
est donnée par amine et yacine ces deux
petits génies du calcul mental qu'on a
reçues dans dit là bas en novembre qu'on
aime beaucoup
regardez ils vous donnent la bonne
réponse aux débutants
dans le dans la première condamnation on
voit là transitoire alors vu donc on a
fait 57 divisés quand on a 50 se diviser
par trois concours de nourriture donc
une idée d'égaliser 9 alors un trafic a
donc on a gardé nos parents la 84'
élargie mais trois avalanches et les
trois heures on a calculé que nous trois
heures était qu'à trois autres employés
liga 6 et 10 plus 15 en plus un trèfle à
quatre feuilles
c'est égal à 10 avenue dans notre calcul
deux trèfles à quatre feuilles de coca 4
plus catchy plus une école plus une
étoile mais ça fait 28 puisque les poids
super tennis - roland dernier quelques
milliards 2 trèfle à trois feuilles
il n'aura ce que montre bühler et
l'horloge et les x à l'école donc
sachant qu'il est égale à 19 soit un dé
plus arrêter des marins ont fait une
fois mise
c'est dégueulasse il leur est commun
sont quatre fois et c'est égal à 4 à 3
feuilles c'est égal à 3 donc voir trois
points des meneurs d'avezzano c'est nous
qui avons grandi et vous expliquer je
vous expliquais non mais c'est très
simple à demain il ya trois étoiles ça
fait 55 donc fait 57 divisé par trois
pour avoir le valeur de l'étoile etc ce
qui nous fait 19 mai accord aussi merde
c'est très simple le trèfle se voyait
bien il ya quand il ya quatre feuilles
quatre feuilles
vous faites 19 là vous savez qu'à 19 ans
donc 19 +4 même temps croit puisque
quatre également de cette donc vous
déduisez que le trêve quand il à quatre
feuilles
eh ben ça fait 27 voilà vous avez
compris ou pas quand ya trois feuilles
ça veut dire que ces trois et quand il
ya quatre feuilles de droit et avec
l'horloge c'est pareil maintenant en
fait et d'après c'est avec ce calcul là
vous avez le vous avez 4 +3 à +3 ça fait
10 vous déduisez en fait que les heures
dans ces trois heures près toutes les
trois et donc là un le 3 3 6 et 7 7
pouces 19 égal à la fois design et voilà
on est monté d'un cran non non non pas
d'un cran 9
bah oui ça oui ça donc c'est un but de
regagner les réseaux non bâti ses plus
belles voitures fois pas du tout c'est
plus une fois 19 bande de remada et vous
comprenez rien mais il manque des
parents c'est l'addition
typique des bêtises donc 3 +36 plus une
fois 19-19 +6 égale 25 tout simplement
de nombreuses personnes ont eu la bonne
réponse chez eux
je vous le dis et isabelle a eu la bonne
réponse maxime est la bonne réponse et
doc gynéco
[Applaudissements]
j'espère qu'ils ont passé une bonne
soirée avec nous il reste encore 2 ten
on va continuer dans l'instant notre
test avec la partie verbale c'est une
partie que vous allez adorer
parce qu'on joue tous avec les mots
allez donc là là ça c'est une autre
forme bailliage aussi il y aura la
dernière partie du test avec espace et
techniques comme la petite préférée
lorsque michel l'espace gemme la
technique c'est avec les volumes les cas
on va se régaler on va se régaler pour
ceux qui ont eu madame tout ça en
quatrième doublé l'an dernier on savait
que vraiment on se régale avec ça alors
maintenir la deuxième partie je vous
connais le classement en dernière
position pour l'instant malgré sa bonne
réponse c'est toujours doc gynéco qui
est dernier avec 22 % de bonnes réponses
doc gynéco donc est bon dernier
vient ensuite deux personnes qui sont à
égalité encore benoît dubois et mathieu
de l'ordre à 44,44 pour sommes pas de
réponse benoîte égalité avec mathieu
vous êtes dans les derniers vous n'êtes
pas du tout sur le prime la layadi prime
ni primé à rien du tout dans la maison
fini le sketch alors mais attendez c'est
pas terminée donc matthieu delormeau 44%
de bonnes réponses ainsi que benoît
dubois vous est avant-dernier et
antépénultième aux biens ce soir j'ai
des foulées de piger balances ton poste
après ensuite vient un groupe avec 50%
de bonnes réponses
un groupe composé de deux personnes
isabelle morini bosc et kelly vdev dit
voilà il est dans ce qu'on appelle un
noyau bas du classement encore moins en
bas de celle du clash on vous dit après
on arrive là dans le ventre mou le
ventre mou yade gilles verdez géraldine
maillet jean michel maire avec 55% de
bonnes réponses
ensuite il qu'on commence à rentrer dans
les bons élèves avec 61% droit de
réponse maxime gay ni valérie bénaïm
benjamin castaldi
magali berda qui a chuté magali berdaoui
ensuite on arrive à la numéro 1 pour
l'instant celle qui est en tête du test
de qi et daniel moreau
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]